>> Raymond: DEMOCRATS LOVE TO
PORTRAY THEMSELVES AS THE PARTY
OF LOVE AND TOLERANCE, BUT ARE
THEY?
WE JUST SHOWED YOU HOW
CHUCK SCHUMER THREATENED TO
SITTING SUPREME COURT JUSTICES,
UNFOLD SCHUMER WASN’T MAKING A
PHYSICAL THREAT OTHERS IN HIS
PARTY HAVE OPENLY THREATENED
VIOLENCE AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS A GUY WHO YOU
UNDERSTAND, MY TESTOSTERONE
SOMETIMES MAKES ME FEEL LIKE I
WANT TO PUNCH HIM.
>> I THINK HE NEEDS TO GO BACK
AND PUNCH HIM IN THE FACE.
>> Raymond: AREN’T THEY
LOVELY?
JOINING ME NOW ARE CONGRESSMAN
MATT GAETZ AND LEE ZELDIN,
CONGRESSMAN SELDEN DOES THAT
SOUND LIKE A PARTY OF LOVE AND
TOLERANCE TO YOU?
>> NOT AT ALL, I AM THINKING OF
STEVE SCALISE WHO ALMOST LOST
HIS LIFE.
ALL OF THE OTHER MEMBERS
REPUBLICAN MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
AND SENATE WHO WOULD HAVE LOST
THEIRS IF NOT FOR THE GREAT WORK
OF THE CAPITOL POLICE.
I REMEMBER THE END OF JUNE
OF 2018, MAXINE WATERS WAS
SPEAKING TO HER SUPPORTERS WITH
A VIDEO THAT WENT VIRAL AND SHE
WAS USING A LOT OF RHETORIC
ABOUT CONFRONTING TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS TO
CONFRONT THEM IN PUBLIC PLACES
AND RESTAURANTS AND MOVIE
THEATERS, GUESS WHAT?
THE FIRST WEEK OF JULY 2018, 1
OF MY CAMPAIGN VOLUNTEERS A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF DONALD TRUMP
WAS TARGETED BY SOMEBODY USING
THE SAME EXACT RHETORIC AND
ALMOST KILLED THIS CAMPAIGN
VOLUNTEER OF MINE WITH HIS CAR.
I CAN THINK OF STORIES FROM 17,
18 FAST FORWARD TO TODAY, WE ARE
NOT SENDING THE RIGHT
MESSAGE, NOT ONLY THE LEADERS
WHO SHARE THIS HYPERBOLIC
RHETORIC BUT ALL THE FOLLOWERS
WHO THEN LOOK AT IT AS A CALL TO
ARMS AND OBVIOUSLY THE NT FOR
THUGS.
>> I MENTIONED JACKSON WHO WAS
SUBJECTED TO THIS SORT OF THING
FOR HER PRO-LIFE STANCE, HAVE
YOU BEEN SUBJECTED TO THIS?
>> WE HAVE HAD A NUMBER OF VERY
FRIGHTENING DEATH THREATS,
TAKING SHOTS AT ME FROM LONG
RANGE.
SOMETIMES A DOUBLE STANDARD WITH
THE FBI UNLESS THEY ARE WILLING
TO INVESTIGATE, BASED ON WHETHER
OR NOT YOU ARE A CONSERVATIVE IN
MY EXPERIENCE WHAT.
I THINK IT’S THE FACT THEY ARE
LOSING, DONALD TRUMP HAS
RESHAPED THE FEDERAL JUDICIARY.
CHUCK SCHUMER LOST ON MERRITT
GARLAND, HE LOST WHEN HE TRIED
TO BLOCK GORSUCH, THEY LOST IN
SPECTACULAR FASHION WHEN
JUSTICE KAVANAUGH.
YOU SEE THE FOLKS ON THE LEFT,
EVEN MORE ANXIOUS AND EVEN MORE
ON PROTECTABLE.
>> Raymond: DEMOCRATS HAVE
BEEN SAYING FOR YEARS THAT TRUMP
IS THE VIOLENT ONE.
>> WHAT MR. TRUMP HAS DONE IS
CREATE AN ATMOSPHERE THAT
CONDONES VIOLENCE, THAT ACTUALLY
INCITES PEOPLE’S MOST EMOTIONAL
AND VIOLENT FEELINGS.
I TOLD THE PRESIDENT DIRECTLY
THAT I THOUGHT HIS LANGUAGE WAS
NOT JUST DIVISIVE BUT
INCREASINGLY DANGEROUS.
>> IT IS THE LANGUAGE IN OTHER
COUNTRIES, AND IT IS DANGEROUS
FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> CONGRESSMAN SELDEN, DID ANY
OF THEM CONDEMN WHAT SCHUMER
SAID YESTERDAY?
>> NOT THAT I KNOW OF, THAT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS SO
FRUSTRATING.
OF ALL THE DOUBLE STANDARDS THAT
WE HAVE SEEN, SINCE DONALD TRUMP
HAS GOTTEN ELECTED WE SAW IT
LAST YEAR IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES WITH ALL THE
ANTI-SEMITIC RHETORIC, THE
DOUBLE STANDARDS OF MORAL
EQUIVALENCIES.
WE SETTLE OUR SCORES AT THE
BALLOT BOX, ALL THIS
INFLAMMATORY RHETORIC IT BELONGS
THERE.
AS A CONSEQUENCE OF THE LAST
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION, THAT’S
HOW YOU END UP WITH
NEIL GORSUCH, AND BRETT
KAVANAUGH.
LET US DO OUR JOBS, BUT
CERTAINLY AS YOU POINT OUT
WHETHER YOU ARE IN CONGRESS OR A
MEMBER OF THE MEDIA, CALL IT
ACCURATELY IF YOU WANT TO GO
THERE.
IT WAS A THREAT, THERE IS NO
ACCEPTABLE EXCUSE, NO ACCEPTABLE
EXPLANATION FOR IT.
YOU CAN’T CUT IT ANY OTHER WAY,
IT WAS A THREAT.
>> Raymond: IS CONGRESS MATT
GAETZ WAS SAYING, I THINK HE
FEARS LOSING THE SUPREME COURT.
I WANT HER REACTION TO THE
OUTCOME OF THE CORONAVIRUS
YESTERDAY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" REPORTED
THAT ON MONDAY THE CDC APPEARED
TO HAVE REMOVED FIGURES ON THE
AGENCY WEBSITE COUNTING HOW MANY
AMERICANS HAD BEEN TESTED.
CONGRESSMAN GATES, VERY QUICKLY.
HAVE THEY TOLD CONGRESS WHY THEY
ARE DOING THIS?
>> YES, BECAUSE WE HAVE
DEMOCRATIZED ACCESS TO TESTING
TO THE STATE LEVEL, WE ARE
ACTUALLY DOING A GREAT DEAL MORE
TESTING NOW AND KEEPING THAT
DATA IN REAL-TIME ON THE CDC
WEBSITE IS LESS PRODUCTIVE THAN
HAVING STATES DO THE TESTING AND
THE REPORTING.